good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy Thursday that
should be a Friday because I'm feeling
Friday Vibes but
nevertheless she persisted nevertheless
it's a Thursday which is really wild
coming from us considering yesterday was
our first show of the week but this week
has just been great meetings meetings
meetings podcast podcasts photo shoot
photo shoot photo shoot so I'm actually
vlogging my week in New York and last
night I had some down time so I started
putting it all together and it is so
juicy and like jam-packed so one you
should become a patreon member so that
you get it when it goes live you could
see what we've been up to and why today
feels like a Friday even though
technically for us it's like a Tuesday
but not at all no it's been a long week
I've been very social this week my
social battery is at an all-time low
like we're supposed to go to the
Internet like there's a 75 chance I
don't show up like I'm not okay no and
everyone's trying to make the dinner
like a big party pregame Etc just dinner
yeah you guys are listening we need to
like dinner now we need to level
everyone's expectations for tonight
because I have nothing to give but you
always say that and then there she is
well I show up for my girl I show up for
my girl that's what you're saying you
but I don't don't need to go to the
clubs no I show up for my girl okay
that's one thing about me I'm gonna show
up for my girl it's for me then
um we've got a great show last night was
Real Housewives of Beverly Hills
second to last episode and the season
premiere of Salt Lake City which I did
not watch because I forgot and I wasn't
in the mood I watched because I had to
watch everything live because on my TV
in my hotel like I had to watch
commercials and so I watched Beverly
Hills live in Salt Lake City and then
Watch What Happens Live I'm literally
two and a half hours I did all my
homework oh good okay so I got Beverly
Hills yeah and that's really the most
important thing that we need to recap
and then I'll just set the scene for
where we're at in Salt Lake City nothing
crazy happened but the Dynamics have
shifted and that is not what they
usually are speaking of different cities
I think you have announcement for
everyone today don't you I have a number
of announcements okay I just actually
have to start with the most important I
got my hair cut
I read about it at page six and um it's
a different newly Sun Life it's a whole
new
sometimes you get a haircut it's like
okay your hair was done yesterday and
it's done today but like you guys can
really tell the difference it's shorter
it's healthier if you guys are curious
what I ask for especially in this case I
said cut off take off everything dead
and then add layers but sometimes when
they take off everything dead it's going
to be shorter than you want so you have
to be prepared for that but if it's dead
it's dead and I don't want it so that's
what I said and I'm really happy you
look great and I feel lighter I got
Botox so I'm shifting towards less
expression I still can raise my eyebrows
and stuff today but tomorrow you
couldn't catch me you won't you won't
know what she's feeling she'll be a
mystery me emoting tomorrow mysterious
girl you're gonna have this air of
mystery tomorrow love that for me just
like Bruno and Theo's friend mystery
and other I guess equally important
announcement is that I am doing a spritz
meet and greet on Friday October 7th in
where is she going you guys will never
guess let me guess let me guess here
here's a clue
spring summer here's a clue joggers
I'm going to Atlanta yeah that's right
meet and greet on Friday October 7th at
4 30 p.m at Total Wine at acre Mills in
Atlanta that is 2955 Cobb Parkway
Southeast Atlanta Georgia 30339 if you
want to put that and what country is
that USA USA no like if you're in
Atlanta not into your navigation it's um
Total Wine at acre Mills in Atlanta we
but between like the month of October
like we are hitting the New York
toasters we are hitting the Georgia
toasters we see you we appreciate you
and we're gonna come meet and greet you
yeah there will be meeting in there
we'll figure it out there will be a
greeting for sure and I think there
might be sleeting
what's that it's not like weather sleep
sleep yeah I don't know if they get a
lot of sleet in Georgia there will
definitely be heating because I get
really hot at those meet and greets you
do I'm pretty temperature controlled
yeah when we did the one in Fort
Lauderdale I literally like my hair was
huge I was not okay sweat drumming down
my neck and Jackie was like can we turn
the air down it's like a little cold in
here catching a chill everyone was like
on death's door it was so hot and that
store and Jackie was like
sweater I could go for a cashmere snack
a little cashmere
um so that'll be super fun and what else
should we catch up on before we dive in
what are the stories looking for a
little more Jacks today you're like I
missed her I just could use some more
Jacks in my life I'm on Sophia with an F
today we recorded together this week it
was so much fun I'm so glad the episode
is like here now and now I don't have to
wait because we had such a great chat it
was actually my first time meeting her
which is crazy because she's done the
show a few times but I'm gonna talk
about her like all the time all the time
and I talk about her podcast all the
time because I'm always listening to it
she always has great guests and she's so
funny she is so funny she's so funny she
posted a clip where you were like we've
literally never met because like I was
on maternity leave and she's like really
jacking using your baby as an excuse
she's like low-key like like a comedian
no she's hysterical and the whole
episode was so funny and I love her
podcast I listen to it all the time so I
was very excited to be on it so check
that out after you listen to today's
episode don't go anywhere yeah don't go
anywhere but it's really good stuff and
she asked me some like really great
questions I'm always curious what when I
go on another podcast like what people
want to ask me about like what do they
see that I'm doing that they're like
talk to me about so what did she ask you
about she asked me like what it was like
to be a redhead especially growing up
and like it's such a big part of my
story but nobody has ever really asked
me that in like on a podcast or anything
it was such a great question I just felt
so seen 100 so what was it like growing
up around that's hard it's really hard
and fellow redheads know you just when
you're a kid you just want to be like
everyone else you want to wear what
everyone else is wearing like you don't
want to stand out you don't want like so
much attention it'll be like different
yeah and when you're a redhead you have
no choice no like we couldn't go out to
dinner and like run run in with some run
into someone who wouldn't make a comment
about yourself I don't even care about
like oh I went to dinner with my family
and someone was like over like I care
about school you know I can handle the
comments from like adults adults like oh
what beautiful hair but like at school
you just like where did she come from
kids school you want to blend in that's
true and so we had some really great
convos check that out I love that I'm
gonna listen to it you shouldn't yeah I
think you'll get to know me on a deeper
level I usually wait for all the reels
to come out like I love Sophia's like
tick tocks and rails one thing about me
like if your podcast has vertical video
like I'm in yeah I'm in that's why
you're in on the morning toes I'm all in
on the morning toast I'm gonna get the
morning toast tattooed on my Beijing you
should no actually if I really wanted to
get it appropriately placed I think I
would get it on my fupa
why because I just feel like my fupa is
the third co-host like I talk about it
all the time
and she's getting smaller but like I
think it's really important to know like
I still have a football like a big one
is that sad it's like I've lost 35
pounds and like my food was not actually
not gotten smaller well as stated like
your fuba is third co-host like she's
not gonna just leave so right no she's
stubborn she's not going anywhere 100
pry her away with her cold dead hands
I'm speaking of cold dead hands did you
see that High School Musical the musical
The Series has recast some of the losers
from the original
um Lucas grabiel Bart Johnson the
dancing cheerleader Corbin blue and
Taylor the Scholastic decathlon girly um
they're all joining the series for the
next season good yeah love that I'm
really happy for Mark Johnson me too all
his hard work paid off but they will
have to play like the actors
because the thing about that show it's
like High School Musical exists as a
movie yeah no you're right it's So Meta
it's so weird it's psychotic it's a lot
to wrap your head around High School
Musical the musical the series it can be
confusing for the campers like HSM tsts
that's a lot so I'm ready to dive in if
you are yes so without further Ado to do
actually I'm sorry I need an update
everyone needs an update on the choice
Brothers in your house um the Detroit's
brothers are in my house
and they are doing so well and for the
first night since Bruce got here he
slept in my bed with me last night and
it was
so Heavenly I woke up with like a sense
of peace until well I woke up with a
sense of Peace because I woke up
thinking it was Friday and then I was
woke up thinking it was Friday too and
honestly when I found out that it wasn't
in fact Friday like I don't remember a
time in my life where like the Earth
shattered around me is largely and
loudly as it did this morning just
because we have a
Fortress day today yeah we do we have so
much to do today honestly Moguls Mogul
so you're saying my boy got an A-Plus on
his report he's been nothing short of
wonderful no accidents he's very he
loves to bark it's kind of annoying but
he's excited so I'm excited he won't be
silenced no
no and if he was it would be because he
was silenced not because he was silent
never be silent no never mommy's angel
I'm so proud of you mommy loves you so
I miss my Streisand he's working really
cute he's working on his Memoirs at
Claudia's house Memoirs of stress end I
think he's gonna call it shifting
streisands that's good but my time as a
Strife brother I think it's going to be
called Memoirs of a streza
that's what I think sound off in the
comments what should Grace call his
Memoir what should my dog call his
Memoir yeah well not you calling him a
dog just so people know what the [ __ ] I
know I know if you're new here this is
your first day Bryce is my baby boy dog
if you're watching on YouTube this is
what he looks like and he's an angel
from heaven up above and he's working on
his Memoirs Memoirs of streisa Shifting
streisands that's a really good one too
yeah
and at least he has options what would
Theos be called
to do do I you know something like that
do tattoo
something like yeah
you remember or like
with further Ado yeah without no further
introduce
we gotta Workshop so sound off in the
comments what should Bruce and Bryce's
trice's Memoirs be called unless they
co-author it no
there you have a rivalry have you seen
it yet uh what do you mean have I seen
it I was the one who told you about it
the first time Bryce was literally with
me sit on Theo to get him out of the way
yeah no the thing is is it's not really
going to come to a head because they're
not confrontational people but
um there is like this undercurrent of
jealousy and and real Strife between the
two the strikes they're The Strife
Brothers
and um they're definitely keeping each
other at arm's length while Bruce is
staying with us for sure but when they
were in Florida they were getting along
better than ever so I think it's just
like something about this town no it's
claustrophobic so competitive no like
they had room to breathe when they were
out together at your house in my
apartment there's nowhere really to run
there's only room for one king it's true
yeah oh we have Royal news today so
let's get into it so without further Ado
here are the past five stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
solostove we're entering Fallen there's
just really something special about fall
that brings us all closer together I
think it's the chili on the stove but it
could be you know the crisp air the
changing of the leaves the new boots you
got but with the smokeless fire pit from
solo stove you can create fabulous
moments easier than ever enjoy all the
warmth and comfort of a fire pit plus
portability quick setup and cleaning and
best of all no smoke so if you want to
upgrade your backyard with a solo Stove
fire pit you can create story worthy
moments with the without the Fireside
fumes so having a nice like outdoor fire
pit is a real luxury in life and to get
like a big one built in your house is so
expensive and then like you can only use
it at your house but with solo stove
it's a much more affordable way to get a
fire pit they're engineered to be
smokeless and then literally when you're
done with it like oh you're going on a
trip going camping throw it in the trunk
it's really a no-brainer if I had a
house I would buy a solo stove and I
don't even have a house and I do have a
solo stove because we love to take trips
to the mountains you know check out
OS type of family it's super built to
last the stainless steel construction is
designed to regulate airflow burn more
efficiently there'll be so little smoke
you'll wonder how there's so much fire
it's the perfect Catalyst for getting
outside spending time with family and
friends and you can build lasting
memories around a solo Stove fire pit
they're brilliantly engineered to be
easy to use and built to last it's easy
to light with just a few bits
of starter your fire will be blazing in
minutes they are so confident that
you'll love it they offer a lifetime
warranty and a free 30-day return policy
so you can use it for 30 days you know
if it's not for you which are you okay
you can return it no ifs ands or Bots
solo Stove fire pits are truly
everything of the sort you can prepare
for your best outdoor memories and save
big during the solo stove fall event
plus if you use promo code toast at
solostove.com you'll get an extra ten
dollars off that's
s-o-l-o-s-t-o-v-e.com promo code toast
for ten dollars off on top of the Fall
event deals hurry the fall event ends
November 10th so you can save at the
fall event and then also get another 10
off at solostove.com promo code toast
great okay our first story is Royal news
I said we would be talking about the
queen until October and I'm so sorry Her
Majesty up above but I failed you
because it was fine like we exhausted it
for sure no everyone like didn't want to
hear about it anymore but I shouldn't
have paved to the pressure no you should
have and I'm glad you did I wish that we
had been talking about her every single
day since no I feel really good about
what we did we'll make up for it today
because Queen Elizabeth II's cause of
death has been revealed no for sure I
got this people notification this
morning and I didn't even click it she
was murdered because when you're 97 like
the cause of death is
um
God like it's not well her official
cause of death is old age but no it I
was curious it is yeah that's a cause of
death yeah like natural causes as
opposed to like she got sick with
something right murder right poison
poison my money's on Camilla Parker in
the in the saloon with the vial what's
also interesting is the certificate
revealed that she died on September 8th
at 3 10 pm so remember that day we were
like is she already dead they're waiting
to make the announcement wait but they
found out it was a work day it was a
work day but they're ahead of us in time
so was it a Friday that we found out
yeah I never said Friday you said
Saturday no I didn't
I said September 8th 3 10 pm usually
I'm telling you something's off with me
because you said Saturday
roll it back no no you know what on that
one I might be wrong and then the royal
family announced the Queen's passing
three hours later so it was three hours
we got it the same day and I feel like
some people thought it was 24 hours 12
hours so three hours
that feels right just like a redhead's
rating I you don't listen but that's an
inside joke with us that feels right
that not you attacking me again
people sounded off in the comments
yesterday and by the way there was
literally equal there was like a lot of
people said that that you attacked me
first
like I was actually reading the comments
because I wanted to know like am I
delusional
um it was mixed but I would say I don't
know that it was equal oh I would I
would say if maybe if it wasn't equal
then it was more on my side
yeah okay so let's tally It Up Sound Off
in the comments foreign
yeah no I don't feel like they would
have kept that from us because there
needs to be a sovereign like if
someone's dead like they need to move
quickly yeah but also I guess like you
know if they wanted to lie like they
could lie on the death certificate but I
don't think that they don't no because
that's piece of History yeah no I don't
think that they did I don't think that
they did because I don't think there was
anything nefarious about her death like
her time it wasn't just how long did it
take for everyone to get there well
that's the thing now we can look back at
the footage of like Harry getting to
Balmoral and they were taking a long
time and I think it was because everyone
was having trouble getting there so now
that we know what time she died we'll
know who was there for her last breath
yeah but we know that Harry wasn't there
yeah
I don't know who else might have missed
it also I did see an article that she
died with her corgis in the room
oh that's beautiful that's really really
like I'm I'm moved and I feel like
that's something you needed to know no
I'm deeply moved by that
I really am yeah also a little more
Royal news just section one subset B
because I won't I won't make it two
stories I don't want to offend everyone
Harry and Megan are desperate to edit
their Netflix show and Memoir after the
king's Queen's death
Prince Harry and Meghan Markle are
making a dramatic u-turn on their
upcoming who's this from this is from
page six okay in their upcoming projects
in the wake of Queen Elizabeth's death
multiple sources told page six the Duke
and Duchess of Sussex have been working
on a docu-series as part of their
multi-million dollar Netflix deal for
more than a year Netflix Chiefs had
hoped to air the docu-series in December
after the fifth season of the crown
premieres on November 9th now we're told
that the couple want to make more edits
to the hotly anticipated show which
would potentially push back its release
until later in 2023. also Harry's Memoir
originally scheduled for release from is
it called shifting stresses
original it's called
um
I'll have to work on it yeah
um I thought you actually had the title
no no no I wonder what it's going to be
called you know what I think it'll be
called I want to say one thing I want to
say one thing and I hate to be like a
hater of Megan and Harry because I feel
like they get a lot of hate in a lot of
it like is unnecessary
but like for people who wanted privacy
like they're doing a lot they're doing a
lot like a docu-series like that's
really low level it's giving living
Lohan like it's a lot that's all I want
to say yeah like they came here for
privacy to escape they have more now
after all these projects they did they
have more money than God they don't need
to do things for a while and like it's a
lot that's all I'm gonna say when are we
going to like move on I mean I've
forgotten that that's what they said
initially privacy because it seems like
the last thing they want is privacy you
don't do a podcast if you want privacy
no a podcast about other people that
actually that I understand A docu-series
and A Memoir like that's not private
yeah that's about your life well a
memoir is like something you can just
put out aside from like a press tour and
the fact that you're like gonna probably
spill a lot of tea it's some that's like
I feel like you could be a private
person and write no I actually don't
think so not the way that I feel like
this is the way that I feel like this
book is going to be too also considering
his book was supposed to come out in
November it's already been pushed back
until sometime next year because of the
Queen's death so it's like well one so
the queen was still alive you would have
published this book book that's
obviously
too offensive to publish now that she's
dead no I think but okay so my question
about the Netflix thing and it applies
to the book too first of all I love like
Harry not handing in any of his projects
on time
um like that's literally in school
do you think that the show is being
edited because a it was too
disrespectful to the queen now that
she's dead or now that The Queen Is Dead
they can spill more tea like they don't
like she was the one who really
according to them like their
relationship is definitely severed with
the family but the queen and them are
good lilibet like she was their Ally
according to them so now that she's gone
now is it all bets are off are they
gonna make it worse or better that's an
interesting point one that I hadn't
considered I thought that they wanted to
take stuff out also many Royal experts
have said that King Charles
is holding off giving the title of
prince and princess to their children
until these projects come out
no if I was Prince Charles like I might
do that too it's a shrewd move yeah no
it's like you can't take it away once
you have it it can't be like tip for
like I mean maybe you could but that
would look really bad and to like punish
the kids no it ain't right but it's like
you want to be in the folder no let's
see right right right no that's very
interesting so
um I guess
says they wouldn't be editing it to
downplay some of the things they said
about Charles Camilla William and Kate
now that Charles is like the official
King perhaps and maybe just because
they're trying like if it's coming out
well one I do think they should push it
because anything that comes out in the
next few months like people are feeling
very Pro Queen bro Queenie and I think
this has reminded a lot of people of
like the role that they do play yeah it
would be distasteful it's not their time
yeah no you're it's not the time to
speak your truth that's true
so I I mean I knew that they had this
Netflix deal I feel like I've spoken
about it I guess just now in this moment
it's really settling in for me that like
they're doing a reality show you want to
call it a docu-series it's a reality
show coming out Colton it's Rich Kids of
Beverly Hills like it's a reality show
um and I'm only now kind of ingesting
that and it's hella tacky I'm sorry it
is especially for two people who we've
all championed to like have their
privacy you know yeah there's a lot of
things you can do as a public figure I
feel like there are a lot of good
examples of celebrities who like do do a
lot but I still don't feel like in the
slightest they've been like Overexposed
and Harry and Megan are and it's
partially that like you know the same
way Chrissy Teigen like people keep
writing about them maybe not to their
like they wouldn't prefer it that way so
I think part of it is like it's a lot of
overall exposure at this point but they
keep doing more projects and like
revealing more and I'm just feeling like
um it's a lot in the words of Tasha no
to do a podcast to write a book and a
docu-series the podcast doesn't bother
me because honestly I was disappointed
in a sense that it was literally about
other people and like she was you know
women in media narrative Heroes like two
episodes so I think eventually if you
want to do a podcast like once a week
for the rest of your life like you're
gonna have to share let me tell you my
favorite thing about Harry and Megan is
that they have all these projects and
literally three things have come out you
know what I mean like yeah they have
Netflix they have book they have Spotify
and so far right Disney plus and apple
mental health so far we got two episodes
of a podcast I love that they took all
these projects and literally never put
anything out it's it's actually funny
and also didn't Harry also get like a
job for a mental health company yeah
that was like you know PR like he got a
job like is he still working there I
don't know but the people on Tick Tock
are gonna love him because if you're an
influencer you have to work hard
yeah you have to be multi-hyphenate so I
don't know
um
I don't know how I feel about this
honestly I hope I really do hope because
at the end of the day these people are
family I'm never I'm I never advocate
for families being broken I think you
know no matter what's happened
as family like you can always find your
way back to each other you really can so
hopefully this update
um is a good sign
yeah I I just feel like
the break has already come like
but you can always find your way back to
family
I don't know for these people I really
don't know like they made their choice
and they one they left and I think when
they left everyone was like okay this is
like what's best for you and and you're
not gonna you're gonna live in Canada
and you're not gonna be a part of a
royal family and like I can understand
how that's not for everyone to do right
but I don't think that's what what
caused the huge break and but then there
was Oprah right I think and like that's
you really can't take that back right
and I think the queen and I from what
I've been seeing recently too like the
queen loved Harry she was he was her
favorite and so I think that was them
that was their like watered-down version
of stuff like for her sake right now
that she's gone I think it's all better
I think Charles and will I think they
all hate each other no I think I think
she was the glue for sure yeah
um and she definitely had a very soft
spot for Harry because
he was definitely her favorite and I
think he had a soft swap for her and
like
held back yeah right that was their
version of holding back so like there's
more yeah but it sounds like now that
they're going back and editing all this
stuff it says to make it better yeah
so you'd like so what you're saying is
with the death of Queenie we're getting
further away from a reunion yes
okay that's so sad because like
obviously this is gossip and we all like
you know we like you know feed off of it
but it's a family and it's very sad
brothers be like you and I not talking
to be terrible yeah but like for me it
was sad three years ago and now it's
just the no now now it still city is
what it is it's still sad like you know
what it makes me sad especially after
last night's Beverly Hills
oh my God I was so emotional during that
conversation yeah I just I was so I had
so many conflicting feelings yeah I have
a deep hatred for Lisa Rena oh deep that
I'm not conflicted about honestly
it was
it was crazy to see someone so and I
don't use this word lightly so evil
and so knowingly coming between families
getting so you could see the joy she was
getting out of it was giving Denise
you're so angry and you know I I do
blame I do partially blame Kyle for not
seeing that yeah because In This Moment
Like Kyle is has every right to be upset
Kathy said bad things about her
um but the fact that she's been around
these women for so long and been on the
show for song she's not dumb and she
couldn't see how manipulative Lisa was
being
and even though Kathy really had no
right to be angry because she was there
apologizing and she came she swallowed
her [ __ ] Pride tail between her
legs tears in her eyes and I believed
her but Kathy now after this
conversation Kathy has every right to be
angry now the fact that she like that
her sister refuses to see refuses to be
blind to the fact that Lisa is making
this into if you ever said to me like
you're my sister but these girls are
like oh my God
that what's that mean all right I'm
gonna head out literally literally
they've been like since what I that was
a crazy [ __ ] thing and you know what
some people are like
maybe aren't so close with their family
and they have friends who are like
family but then you
then let's call the relationship what it
is like then The Sisterhood is there's
nothing back to where they were right
you know it was we'll get into the room
we'll get into it but it's always sad
right when it's family particularly yes
agreed okay next story I would just have
to mention this because everyone's
talking about it the try guys the try
guys I need you to explain as best as
possible what it is yeah I have no idea
there are a group of YouTubers that got
popular
um because they try things so they're
the try guys they make videos like
trying stuff it's very simple love that
I actually and they have a podcast and
they are going to pause their podcast
for a week amid the Scandal because of
Ned Fulmer's infidelity I made a tick
tock I was like somebody please explain
to me what oh my phone's over there
someone please explain to me what all
this is um and let me read the comments
too because you know the toasters were
really helpful right a lot of The
Toasters are like big try guy fans so
this was like big breaking news thank
you so I guess I could have read an
article explaining what it is but I
wouldn't like trust an article to
actually give me like the the
information and I I want to hear from
the horse's mouth and experts
um okay
the tripod is what oh that's a cute name
very cute people are like it's literally
my childhood like I'm obsessed with the
try guys hold on these comments are like
yeah it's so crazy how people could be
so famous these days like Millie like
oh and the same it's
okay they started as like one of the
content channels on BuzzFeed okay that's
what I was thinking and then they went
out on their own and they have like a
super successful YouTube Life podcast
life and they're these guys who try
stuff
and one of them is Ned he's married and
it surfaced on Reddit that there were
pictures of him making out with a woman
in public having an affair and then to
add another layer it's this woman who
works for the try guys so it was like HR
violation when the photos surfaced and
hours later they announced like Ned is
not with us anymore
yeah okay to Arielle and everyone loves
Ned and Ariel like ship ship ship so
like people are taking it personal now I
do think it's funny how like you can
have an affair
um and they get fired from your job I
guess the part that makes it like
fireable is that the woman you were
having an affair with works for the
company right so um that I understand
but like like let's say I started having
an affair and you kicked me off the
podcast that would be insane it's weird
when like your personal life you know
what it reminds me of KFC yes oh my God
twin flames twin flames um yeah because
like he was getting dragged on the
internet and like at work for having an
affair and like it's bad to have an
affair but like that really has nothing
to do with your job yeah the only thing
is like Barstool it's like their
personal lives are fun yeah but he
didn't lose his job he just had to deal
with it and I think that like actually
in hindsight it was punishment laid out
like that was yeah it was punishment
pregnant like it was really bad yeah
um and somehow like the toast group was
involved do you remember yeah I don't
remember the details like the way one of
my biggest life regrets to pull out the
list of my life regrets not getting in
the cop car not going to the Kanye West
concert and starting the morning
toasters Facebook group that will go
down history is one of the biggest
regrets of my life like
um
and also on the list of stories I tell
multiple times you can add the Keenan
Thompson Uber driver thing oh yeah yeah
I don't think I wrote that list out yet
let's start let's start Claudia's rep
repeated stories obviously Jess's
funeral even though like we've shamed
you into stopping mentioning it and you
know an ironic way it was [ __ ] up okay
second thing I mentioned Keenan and his
SNL Uber drivers
Uber drivers what else do I
like constantly repeat
sound off in the comments yeah like what
stories are you guys done hearing from
me okay
um okay good I'm glad we're keeping a
list of that okay so the try guys um are
pausing their podcasts his infidelity
um I can't believe this is such a big
story considering I've never heard of
these people on the end of the fair yeah
no it's like a niche corner of the
internet but a big one and he had an
affair it's like
it's like crazy I guess like people have
affairs every day you know not that it's
okay but it's just like it's not that
crazy it's not like one of them like
murdered the other and he's and now he
won't be a try guy no but he released a
statement being like it was Mutual
decision I need to focus on my wife and
my family they have kids like it's bad
like I like I know people like the try
guys but I like the strike guys by the
way try guys greater than try guys and
they would never pull something like
this no no they value family honor they
honor those values Faith Family
fluff I don't know
a Lot Faith Family fluff
so that's what's going on with the try
guys uh
if you're like a try girl
um I'm sorry it's it's hard when like
you know the show you at the end of the
day like your favorite podcast is
breaking up or not even breaking up just
shifting like it'll never be the same
again that must have been how people
felt when the breath got canceled like
for real yeah it's crazy but look at us
now like the toast is so much better
than the breath so in it maybe in a year
from now you'll be like you know I'm so
glad that guy had left it's so much
better without him you know yeah maybe
but no one had to leave like we still
had like original recipe actually we had
to leave but at least we were still
together yeah yeah yeah and it was like
there we go like that's the vibe
whatever it takes I know I can make it
through
are you ready for our next story only if
it's the next story that's brought to
you by kitch yes Hair Care is the new
skincare and there's one brand that has
taken it to the next level with a cult
like following kitchens created
game-changing Essentials that beauty
enthusiasts swear by from satin
pillowcases to time saving towels
kitchen nose hair care doesn't stop in
the shower like when you have as much
hair as me like hair care is a full
routine and I really just took for
granted that I have good hair for over
the last couple years but as you get
older like that's like not you can't
rely on that like you actually have to
start taking care of your hair I've
started sleeping with a satin pillowcase
that I got from Kitsch it's made a huge
difference in my hair like I don't have
to give myself a full blowout every
morning and also my skin
um so I also have like claw clips from
Kitsch here's what they offer they were
started in 2010 just selling hair ties
but they hustled they dreamed and they
are now a self-funded female founded
carried in over 20 000 retail locations
so the satin pillowcase um eye masks and
caps are vegan and cruelty free and it's
not like Silk which is made from silk
worms they are so good for your hair and
your skin while you sleep it's nice to
be proactive without having to do
anything like just going to sleep you
know they also have shampoo and
conditioner bars which are super good
for the environment it's all a part of
bottle free Beauty they have heatless
satin curling rollers so if you don't
want to run a curling iron through your
hair every single day I have the
heatless curlers but I learned about
them before they became a sponsor I
learned about it from Tick Tock because
they went like crazy viral on Tick Tock
um you literally don't need like a
hundred dollar curling iron anymore you
just need your heatless curlers and you
can reuse them they have quick dry hair
towels which is so good for someone like
me because my hair
um will stay wet for 24 hours it works
like a dream and their classic hair ties
and scrunchies so they are offering 30
off your entire order at Mike kitch.com
toast that's thirty percent off anything
and everything at my kitchen which is
spelled m-y
k-i-t-s-c-h.com slash toast one more
time is mykitch.com toast to get 30 off
your order great thank you so much
Claudia you're welcome for all the songs
and all the way so you are what is the
word I'll Google it I kind of like not
knowing and we can make something up
yeah what can I say except get welcome
for all the links and all the codes that
you save oh that's so good yeah it's
giving jingle it's giving jingle but you
wanna know
what can I say except you're welcome for
the tides of sun the sky hey it's okay I
like my better
but I knew I knew I was missing
something yeah I knew our next story
Chloe Grace Moretz is opening up about a
throwback throwback CGM she is talking
about a meme with an altered photo
liking her to a Family Guy character
that made her a recluse with anxiety so
I'm gonna show you I'm just familiar
with the meme if you remember oh I do so
Chloe Grace Moretz has admitted that a
viral meme mocking her appearance made
her withdraw from the spotlight and left
her dealing with anxiety the actress
told hunger magazine that an internet
joke where her photo was altered to make
her resemble a long-legged Family Guy
character resulted in her suffering from
body dysmorphia of course quote I just
remember sitting there and thinking my
body is being used as a joke and it's
something that I can't change about who
I am and it is being posted all over
Instagram
oh my God I'm sorry like okay it's just
coffers for Chloe
on social media platforms an image of
her carrying a pizza in a hotel was
posted next to the cartoon Persona legs
go all the way up Griffin this photo got
manipulated into a character for Family
Guy with the long legs and the short
torso and was one of the most widespread
memes at the time the actress told the
publication about the 2016 snap in real
life she looked Chic in black shorts and
black heels that showed off her figure
she explained everyone was making fun of
my body and I brought it up with someone
and they were like oh shut the [ __ ] up
it's funny
no I wouldn't have told her shut the
[ __ ] up it's funny because she's
entitled to her feelings but I would
have you know I would have made I would
have tried to make her feel better being
like people aren't making fun of the
actual picture of you it's an edited
version of you of you so it's not really
your body I would have like I think I
would focus on that disassociate it's
actually not you that they're making fun
of it's an edited it's still painful
especially when it's so widespread and I
feel really good knowing that I don't
think I ever posted that photo I don't
um it's not like an iconic meme photo
for me but for her obviously like it
shook her I think Chloe I was thinking
about Chloe Grace Moretz like a month
ago like so Random like what the [ __ ]
happened to her like she was so Poppin
well she just said she just made her a
recluse no but like I don't think like
the the enormous drop in her career came
from this meme
yeah just feels like she was everywhere
all at once and then never seen again I
just feel like now there are so many
like at the time she was like one of one
but now it feels like there are so many
friends from Netflix flowy face Moretz
is that's so true like so many like
young blonde good actresses yeah because
you know who she kind of looks like who
Miss Flo
yeah yeah no you're 100 right there's
just like a dime a dozen cgms now yeah
because like they all like you have
popular from one movie on Netflix and
suddenly you have a whole career and
like 10 million Instagram followers yeah
no you're totally right
so that's really sad I know that is sad
and it's crazy because I feel like you
wouldn't think that something like this
would affect someone so much especially
someone is like famous and talented as
her it's like oh you I just assume that
like she saw that was rolled her eyes
yes but no it really affects people and
you never know what it's gonna be that's
really going to like like be seared into
someone's mind you know what this
reminds me of poot
has Demi spoken about poop yes what has
she said really bothered her really yes
and let me use this as a time to remind
you that Demi goes by she they pronoun
so I will be using the she pronouns
she said like it really [ __ ] her up
because like it because that wasn't even
really Photoshopped it was like this
weird angle like the camera
malfunctioned but like it was her and I
remember her addressing it like not
finding it funny oh I didn't know she
addressed it I didn't know that she
didn't find it funny yeah
yeah that's very similar so that's what
it reminded me of I did not think that's
what you were gonna say I did not think
we'd be talking about CGM today I
totally forgot about Chloe Grace Moretz
yeah well she's on the cover of hunger
magazine looking gorgeous and that's a
low because what is hunger magazine no
but here's the thing when you're a
celebrity you do fake magazines fake
magazine covers for like the pictures to
have and post to Instagram and for pull
quotes and it's just like no it's so
true all fakeness like what the [ __ ] is
Wonderland magazine yeah but numbers are
always on the cover like that's a great
looking couple that's gorgeous she could
post it to her Instagram she can tell
her truth and move on I feel like she
became very
um fashiony during the peak of her
career and maybe that's where she's kind
of been existing because she was like
the face of Louis Vuitton for a while um
maybe she's just like a fashion girly
now
maybe or maybe she's in stuff that we
just don't watch yeah let me go to her
IMDb you love to go to somebody's IMDb
together just to see what projects they
have in the works what I missed along
the way
yes she was that girl for a while you
get kick ass remember that the thing is
obviously you can't be that girl forever
but to go from being that girl to like
someone who's name I genuinely forgot
like that's like a crazy drop but she's
got a lot of stuff going on but nothing
that you've seen and I hope she's happy
I really do yeah me as well you know
wishing her the best are you ready for
our next story it's some exciting
podcasting news is it stassi yeah yeah
stassi's straight up with stassi is back
stassi Schroeder has brought her podcast
back straight up with stassi dropped two
episodes to Premiere yesterday she's I
think she's already charted at number
two in all categories when I checked
last night she was number two she's
still number two good for her and this
is exciting news for the podcast world
because sassy is an OG this must be how
it felt when the breath turned into the
toast like we only made everyone wait
two months and we got two years one does
it yeah but um I think if you're a
really big stassi fan and you loved her
podcast which she had like a lot of
really diary fans like you're really
excited about this she has been
podcasting on patreon so if Like You
Were Dying For content you did have
something
um but I feel like the fact that she
took a long time means like she's gonna
be delivering like extremely different
content because the girl who we know now
is now a mom is two years out of like a
major Scandal is married is very
different I think it'll be like a much
more evolved podcast and I think I mean
that in a positive way yeah but also
like
even this podcast that we've been doing
it like for two years but like it's more
evolved like it's so different eval as a
whole time and I think this is really
exciting for the podcasting world yeah
no honestly I forgot that she's like an
OG podcast she's a pro because it's been
she was podcasting before anyone else
before it was like really considered a
popular thing it was like kind of weird
she was like that [ __ ] no it wasn't so
popular in like this category of like
pop culture Bravo no it was or it wasn't
it wasn't no it was like NPR yeah it was
more like news and yeah Joe Rogan yeah
all of that so I'm glad that she's back
yeah that's really exciting really
exciting and I'm happy for her and
looking forward to hearing more of her
life you just reminded me because we
were talking about like scandals remind
me when we talk about Lisa right now
like just remind me okay I'll say
reminding you yeah and now are you ready
for our fifth and final story that's a
little bit of a conversation piece that
I feel like you're gonna get really
passionate about I love being zealous
yeah so Tom Hanks spoke with People
magazine nope listen and he said that
he's probably made about four pretty
good movies agreed let's go Toy Story
one Toy Story two I'm doing what someone
said Toy Story three Toy Story 4. he
said I've made a ton of movies and four
of them are pretty good I think and I'm
still amazed at how films come together
from a flicker of an idea to the
flickering image on screen the whole
process is a miracle did he say which
ones he didn't so people are now Forrest
Gump speculating big
here's what some people are saying one
tweet Wilson cast wait he won tweet
Forrest Gump Bridge of spies the
terminal The Green Mile I just I don't
know those ones next tweet Gump
Philadelphia Castaway big that is
probably right
I think if it were me Forrest Gump
Sully
100 how did we forget Sully
what else is there oh I guess he was in
Saving Private Ryan the thing is like
the iconic movies that Tom Hanks is
famous for like I do not know except for
Forrest Gump and big there's also Polar
Express uh A League of Their Own no
don't by the way my hatred for Tom Hanks
is relatively new
um I
believe he's had a really astounding
career but up until recently it's like
he doesn't care about preserving the
Dignity of that career he's just like
doing trash yeah and he's acting out
like I saw a video of him like literally
yelling at Paparazzi and like the
paparazzi was wrong like they they
literally came for Rita like they shoved
her away like Rita get the [ __ ] out of
the way like we don't care about you
they were outside Nobu on 57th Street
like it was a crazy video and Tom was
like hi
and I loved it he was defending his wife
but like
he shouldn't been in that situation like
you're Tom Hanks like you like just get
in the car you know what I mean yeah I
just feel like he's kind of like on this
and then you know Pinocchio now he's
doing and the trash dumpster fire
performance in Elvis like and he's been
doing like a lot of press and like I
find his personality like [ __ ]
annoying I really do yeah he should
stick to the screen yeah not to be like
that type like shut up and sing but like
seriously shut up and act yeah when he
goes on late night I'm like I don't
think this man is cute or funny for the
record on Rotten Tomatoes not that that
means anything but it doesn't it means
nothing his highest rated movie is Toy
Story with 100 score okay they're right
about that and his lowest rate is movie
lowest rated movie is my life in ruins
with a 10 score I don't know that film
me neither but I do think I mean
I think objectively he and especially
compared to other actors he's done more
than four pretty good yeah especially
with all the toy stories Captain
Phillips there's probably 15 honestly
like he's had an amazing but like for
him he just sees it as four no and for
us like you're always remembered by that
you've got mail isn't that him
um
is it
who are we talking about again Tom Hanks
uh is it is it is wait let me go to IMDb
oh God please no Tom Hanks he's been in
so many movies IMDb The thing is he was
in that one you gotta have an amazing
career but like unfortunately we live in
a culture where [ __ ] is like so fast
paced like people really only remember
the last thing you did
but not for Tom Hanks I'm not thinking
about Saving Private Ryan like I am
thinking about Elvis so he needs to do
something major but I liked Elvis so I
didn't like him
but it's a good movie he's talking about
the movies not his performance well
that's true the post I never saw oh I
never saw that either that was Watergate
the circle never saw it Sally's so
[ __ ] good so [ __ ] good uh he was
in the Carly Rae Jepsen music video for
I really like you what yeah you're gonna
just Breeze past that yeah I just feel
like I really do that and that's
probably one of the ones I really like
you do you want me do you want me
because I want you to justice for Carly
Rae that's a whole other podcast episode
anything else that I'm seeing that you
would know like Charlie Wilson's War The
Da Vinci Code right he's the main guy I
never watched the movie but I read the
book and I could see it so I felt like I
said I saw the movie Whatever at least
Tom Hanks is self-aware and that's a
quality I think is really really lacking
in Hollywood
he's lacking in Hollywood
okay so I just think that's Sleepless in
Seattle right or is that that other guy
who looks like Tom Hanks I think it's
that other guy who's like so 90s yeah
yeah yeah he's the guy with the boombox
and the big jacket yeah that's him and
he's like always talking about his mouth
closed yeah yeah yeah
um so Tom Hanks needs to do something
really big
oh it is tough
wait no tummies is the guy with the
Boombox no pinx is not the guy with the
Boombox but he isn't Sleepless in
Seattle is what is what you're saying
I'm telling you the Boombox guy and
Sleepless in Seattle guys the same guy
let me just Google Boombox guy they're
gonna know who you're talking about he
stands outside the window with the
Boombox I think the movie is called like
oh
no it's um
is the movie say something yeah yeah I
was gonna be like Sky okay so say if
people are probably screaming screaming
because people especially like uh people
our age like are obsessed with that John
Cusack yes
and John Cusack is Sleepless in Seattle
that's what I just wanted to make sure
because I don't think it's Tom Hanks I
think it is John Cusack Michio John
Cusack let's not forget is related to
Joan Cusack and their mother must be so
proud Tom Hanks
no yes and John Cusack is not in
Sleepless in Seattle that's what you're
saying it seems like he's not he's not
another guy no I don't but Victor Garber
is another guy in it apparently the way
I would lay my life out on the line with
Victor Garber who's in it Matt Smith
who the [ __ ] is he what
Damon Targaryen is in Sleepless in
Seattle show me a picture is he a child
must be like the newborn baby right Matt
Smith Sleepless in Seattle
images she is the mailman oh okay so
like humble beginnings you love to see
it you'd love to see someone out here
hustling and in their 50s like hitting
their stride yeah is he 50
that makes it even weird I would think
well I would say okay maybe 40s
yeah yeah
um
okay so those are the past five people
so you needed to know them feel as
though we need to recap Beverly Hills
okay so with Beverly Hills the whole
episode honestly was boring like until
we got what we needed like I do not need
to see Erica doing therapy I feel like
it's such an invasion of privacy
whenever reality starts do therapy like
I'm like this is so
not my business and also it's like how
can a therapist be equipped for what
Eric is going through no it's so beyond
beyond and extreme like they don't teach
that in therapy school no 100 reality
star I mean definitely divorce they
could cover
um even Scandal maybe like but like this
level public like and also human beings
aren't like meant to process all of this
like Fame and everyone's opinions and
it's just I don't think that I think she
broke the mold a hundred percent
with the Lisa reader thing the
conversation at the end so I was really
surprised because Kathy Hilton is that
[ __ ] she is I'm sorry
when Lisa Rinna said when she was like
wait did all of this start because of
818 like yeah you know that it did and
second of all her saying that Kathy's
jealous of the Kardashians like come on
really that's not at all what it is
that's not at all what it is like first
of all why why would Kathy be jealous of
the Kardashians their daughters are
friends
they've known each other forever Kathy
is enormously successful like they're
like I don't I don't get that no I don't
think that that's true Kathy like never
tried to manage her daughters really
like I I just I think it's apples and
oranges yeah so that was like a
delusional thing to say classic Rena
um and when they got to the house like I
was really surprised to see Kathy come
coming with her tail between her legs
like I didn't think she was that type I
thought maybe she was like maybe this
got so bad because she's like above
apologizing but she's not yeah I thought
she might be like oh this whole reality
show business is not for me this isn't
fun anymore I'm not filming anymore
goodbye that's what I thought too and
the fact that she showed up and then she
said Kyle was like Lisa's coming later
if you want to stay and she stayed I was
like damn
I was impressed with Kathy I was like
really I did not think she was going to
be like that like eating Humble Pie and
she with Kyle she was just so apologetic
and Kyle like pushed back a little bit
and she stood her ground and she was
still apologetic but with Lisa it was
like nothing Kathy was gonna say was
gonna be good enough release and so
Kathy got [ __ ] annoyed and honestly I
agree like how can you just sit there
and like continuously apologize and
apologize and Lisa was having none of it
she was like well we need to get to the
the source of why you have a black heart
a black heart but really like okay
someone can have an off night without
having problems right and then she
starts breaking down she's like a friend
of mine is dying she has cancer like I
broke yeah also when Kathy started
explaining to Kyle and Kyle didn't
believe her but like that's what Kathy
was saying is what we saw like the whole
trip everyone's picking on her like oh
thank you for bringing that up she
didn't get dressed up and I feel like
for her to even like admit yeah this was
probably really big like I think she
felt disrespected the entire trip one
everyone's picking on what she's wearing
reeling on them they're railing on her
tequila three then they don't try her
her to kill and they just like keep
ignoring her and then they go to this
club and she's not dressed to the nines
like everyone else and I think she was
disrespected like all [ __ ] week and
at her age with who she is like that
hurt her I'm so glad that she brought up
the the clothing thing because I brought
it up remember I was like everyone like
making fun of her bag and then her
slippers and it was just like non-stop
making fun of Kathy and it's like what
the [ __ ] and I'm so glad that she
brought it up because I felt validated
I'm like I would have been pissed too
and the way that Kyle was like there's
no way or was it Lisa who was like Kyle
said in her interview she's like that's
not what it was and she compared it to
like the hiding of the purse which is a
practical joke the other thing what they
were doing to Kathy is mocking her yeah
it was so rude and I totally feel that
that is a valid reason for her to have
gotten so upset and she's like in the
room with the bunk beds while Lisa and
who else was staying at that to read but
then living like in like upstairs yeah
and if I was her I would feel
disrespected so then she goes to her
request a song and again she's
disrespected and she snaps
to say it's there's no justification for
snapping like that but I do appreciate
the context of what led her to that
moment and she's still in the wrong and
she has to apologize and she did like
isn't that all we're ever asking of
people is to acknowledge their mistakes
and why I wanted to bring up the whole
like cancel culture thing it's like
because Lisa Rin is that person who's
gonna hold you to your worst moment
forever like doesn't believe in growth
doesn't believe that human beings make
mistakes and it's so hypocritical
because who has made more mistakes than
Lisa Runner right and it's also crazy
that Kathy and I we never like
something's in an old season or five
seasons ago it's like not relevant but
Kathy like knows Lisa Rena as like the
woman who threw a wine glass at her
sister yeah no it's funny how like we
know all these women in a certain way
but the way they know each other the way
Kathy knows lucerna and Cat Lisa keeps
saying like I love Kathy like I've known
her for years no you don't no you don't
you may know Kathy but Kathy doesn't
know you
um Kathy confiding in Lisa that night
was the best thing that ever happened to
Lisa I know and also she was like do you
know that I locked myself in my room so
she was like no because I wasn't even
talking to you the conversation ended
and they went to their rooms and then
Lisa locked her door right for drama so
that she could say I had to lock myself
in my room it's not like she ran away
from Kathy covey's banging on the door
and the door and that's how she would
know it was locked the way I've done a
total 180 on crystal Minkoff like at the
beginning of the season when she was
being literally like so sensitive in the
corner like my feelings yeah
to now when when the producer was like
who do you believe Lisa or Kathy she's
like and the way she said it was like so
iconic I believe Kathy I'm like yes and
you know what to to have that those
convictions when you're being told that
Kathy said bad things about you you're
going to want to believe the person
who's telling you that but she's so
plugged because she knows Lisa Rena is a
shit-starting manipulative liar and
Kathy is really Kathy is too
she's a kind of ditzy like she's not
manipulative she's not calculated at all
like she really does they're trying to
paint her in this light and then next
week's episode looks so good it feels
because everybody feels like Kyle the
wheels are turning for everyone like why
is everything being leaked and you can
see how Erica and Lisa are trying to
take Kathy down to to one to get all the
heat off of Erica for a minute and two
because Lisa just loves to do that
um and it does feel like Kyle um comes
to her senses in a bit and it's like
like you're not letting this go it's
putting me in a bad spot like why won't
you let this go and and even the way
that Lisa Rinna shared Kathy's text
message these women those core five they
protect each other like they definitely
have thousands of text messages being
like let's bring this up but let's not
bring this up like they protect one
another and that's why Erica no that's
my Sutton Crystal and garcelle have
gotten annoyed like in the past year
because it's like they're special rules
for you guys you decide who gets
protected and you decide who gets
exposed and so for her to bring that up
it's it really is [ __ ] up to bring up
what Kathy's text message being like
there's let's be quiet about it like
there's no reason to upset everyone
um they would do that for one another
yes but not for Kyle not for I mean not
for Lisa
not for Kathy and not for Sutton
garcelle and Crystal no Lisa we're gonna
need to do a better job of concealing
when she's so obviously and joyful and
like can smell blood because it was just
so crazy and it makes her look so bad
yeah it really does and the thing is I
believe that you can say something mean
about someone in a really heated moment
and that's not how you feel well yes and
this also applies to Salt Lake City
because a lot of the first episode is
about with what Lisa Barlow said in the
round and I want to know what you think
that's what's literally the same thing
that's why I actually
appreciated Kathy being like I said it
and I didn't mean it but like here's why
I said it I feel like I can never get a
hold of you like you are not really
interested in like a relationship with
me and Kyle like didn't necessarily deny
that she's like it's just a lot to talk
to you and like you don't ask me about
me so it's like I appreciated them at
least acknowledging like I didn't make
this stuff up like I'm hurt because of X
Y and Z and I definitely went you know
out of control on what I said but it
came from a place of like I appreciated
Kathy at least trying to talk about like
there's an origin to these feelings yeah
so it was like actually such a mature
conversation and the way that like Lisa
just shut it down by being so evil I was
really upset by I really was Justice for
Kathy like I don't think Kathy's now
gonna take down Kyle and her family if
it's the last thing she does even if she
maybe said that like I don't think
that's what she's gonna do yeah
yeah
um so
I watched it first maybe five or ten
minutes of Salt Lake City their
relationship is so precarious that like
I think with the two of them they just
have to let [ __ ] go yes they can't get
into so why did you say this and what
did you mean if they really want to
continue I reached that level of like
feeling how I used to feel yeah this is
why I reach that way can we move forward
yeah no you're right because it seems
like they're both really sensitive to
the time when they weren't talking
um and you're right in a relationship
like that you have to at some times like
swallow things yeah like and even though
it's probably hard for Kyle
um to like know that her sister like
said this stuff about her and now she's
just gonna drop it I think she just has
to drop it otherwise they'll go they're
going back circles yeah
so
did Meredith and Lisa on episode one
talk to one another about the rant yes
so episode one started filming two
months after the reunion okay and I like
how they were referring to the reunion
as in L.A in L.A
um and what I found interesting was that
Meredith said that Lisa hadn't called
her once in those two months then
there's a party first episode Lisa goes
up to Meredith and says like I would
love to talk to you I don't think here's
the place but I'm so sorry and
Meredith's like okay cool and then Lisa
starts talking to Seth and gets into a
longer conversation just about how sorry
she is about everything and Meredith's
thing is like you didn't call me for two
months you know how could you be that
and then when their cameras like you
want to be so sorry right then on Watch
What Happens Live Lisa said that she
after the reunion she tried to talk to
Meredith at dinner they all went to
dinner together
like wouldn't hear it and Lisa was like
she just need she needed time and I
needed to give her space that I
understand but to have the first
interaction be on camera is like a
little shallow I agree too but now
Meredith is like Meredith is in not a
great position right now but like she
decides when her and Lisa are friends
again when it's over but instead of just
like waiting and trying to forgive and
move on she's slinging rumors about Lisa
like Lisa sleeps with I'm not saying
Lisa doesn't sleep with people for money
so now I'm not saying Lisa now she's
just as bad as Lisa now the playing
field and Lisa can stop eating crow
because what if what Lisa did with to
you was so so bad now you're doing the
same thing except you're saying anything
you're confessionals when it's like
right tar you know she was on a hot mic
you know and she she was definitely
caught in a bad moment and I do think
like even though it's really hard to
hear what like somebody truly thinks of
you in those moments like there is a way
to get past that in a friendship I don't
think that's what someone truly thinks
of you I think that's what some dark
demon corner of their mind thinks yeah
but that's not the whole picture I agree
what I like how I feel in my angriest
moment is not how I feel no it's maybe a
one percent of how I feel but the rest
of 99 is love and light so that's like a
bad call by Meredith but then also just
a general bad call is like her being so
closed captioning not available
that's the thing about a Housewives of
Salt Lake City that I think makes the
show bad is there are no true
friendships every five minutes someone
is really close with someone that they
hated and we never got real clear how we
got here like all the women are so
scrupulous yeah
and so I'm still I still like Lisa and I
like Meredith I really hope that they
can work it out but I don't think
Meredith will ever really forgive in the
real way but but she was able to forgive
Jen right so maybe and Jen Time After
Time not one bad moment Time After Time
continue to go after Meredith's son
right and honestly the way that Meredith
wouldn't give in to Jen made me had such
respect for her because it's like you
know what this is a show yada yada but
you came for my kid and I had a lot of
respect for how she she stood her ground
and honestly she's it's giving spineless
it's giving like Teddy Mellencamp yes
but sometimes like
you're so angry about something for so
long and then one day it's just
irrelevant I feel that way about Eric
and Sutton yes like when they I love
them when they were fighting it was like
these shows like Erica's literally gonna
kill her I I they'll never speak again
yeah and then when I was watching the
episode last night I was like oh I was
in the past yeah yeah no you're right
you're right about that and by the way I
love the reunion and so sometimes it
just lifts yeah and I think that's a
good thing yeah of course you can't hold
on to that anger hatred yeah so maybe
eventually it will lift for Meredith
just like it Meredith and Lisa just like
it did for Jen but I do think that it is
a good thing and I think it's not uh
just specific to Housewives I think
that's how things happen in life too
because you gotta let go of [ __ ]
otherwise like you become like a
hate-filled person yeah who walks around
with like this chip on their shoulder
yeah but I also think there sometimes
someone does something and it's like
maybe if you didn't have to see them
every day and work with them you would
cut them out and be done with it like
probably Meredith and Jen whenever I've
spoken again if they both weren't
Housewives because I feel like that's
how people operate mostly in their
personal lives but when you're forced to
be around them every day you're forced
to figure it out right you would just
write them out of your life if it wasn't
for the show right
um so hopefully it's a good season like
it's like delayed gratification with
real housewives of Salt Lake City
because you're always waiting for like
the justice no when it doesn't even look
like her guilty plea is part of the
season the reunion
I know it's in like four months and like
will she be on next season like no
she's going to jail right but also why
would Bravo be hiring someone who is
guilty admittedly guilty uh
right so where does Bravo draw the line
now with like hiring criminals No No it
should be like really clear like
Teresa never pled guilty and honestly
Teresa really never should have gone to
jail because Teresa wasn't a guilty
person she was only guilty of being dumb
yeah which is not a crime
um but no you're right now like we have
a admitted guilty person
who is accused of really heinous crimes
are you still employed
no it's a good question I didn't think
about it like that and they dropped the
ax pretty quickly right no you're
totally right
makes you think
so tonight is car well last night was
Kardashians but I didn't watch it at
midnight so we'll watch and then recap
that tomorrow for our final show of the
week can't wait thank you guys so much
for listening to the morning toast the
Millennium Morning Show where we deliver
the past five stories that you need to
have your money through Friday and
YouTube so if you're watching this on
YouTube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up we're
also available as podcast anywhere
podcast can be found so at Spotify
iTunes Stitcher public radio
iradiocastbox all the places where we
listen to podcasts by now someone just
leave a five star review about a
beautiful standing smart we are hope you
guys have an amazing Thursday and we'll
see you tomorrow for Friday Friday you
gotta get down on Friday maybe it could
be a shy day perhaps perhaps a stride
day bye guys